[Music]
hey everyone this is Lucy and I'm here
in Las Vegas for AWS reinvent I'll be
taking you through each day sharing my
insights key takeaways and some of the
behind the scenes for those who don't
know AWS reinvent is an annual Cloud
conference and is the to event for
anyone who wants to learn about the
latest Cloud technology network with
professionals and get a firsthand look
at The Cutting Edge Innovations I
actually flew here a couple of days ago
to explore Vegas since it's my first
time here I was here with two of my
YouTuber friends Jen and Annie and we
visited places like Fremont Street
horseshoe band and had a lot of good
food so yeah it was a lot of fun and I
really enjoyed my time so far but today
I'm very excited because AWS re event
has officially kicked off I'm planning
to attend two talks today and spend the
rest of my time checking out what
reinvent has to offer so let's head over
there now and I'll show you
[Music]
around now n this is what you brought
your Master's thesis on y I did a
wavelet transformation and compression
algorithms I just wish i' had these
illustration skills when I was writing
my Theses but yes there's a time and a
place for
all right so it just came out of a great
session called Cloud operations for
today tomorrow and Beyond we heard from
nandini VP of monitoring and
observability at AWS where she
highlighted the importance of cloud Ops
for today's businesses we also listen to
a few customer stories from JP Morgan
and Disney and it's really cool to hear
that AWS will continue to innovate on
the future of cloud they mentioned that
they're planning to leverage new
technologies like generative AI machine
learning to en has their Cloud
monitoring and operations oh and one
exciting announcement is that AWS has
launched a natural language query
generation feature on Amazon cloudwatch
with this you can easily generate and
refine your Cloud watch data by just
typing in plain language text so super
exciting and now it's time for lunch so
I'll see you
there this going to be our
lunch that look amazing yummy
[Applause]
[Music]
H
TR all
[Applause]
[Music]
right
it's so
cute new leg ACR the world how do
that okay heading back from the event
now uh got my a us Community Builders
flag it's day two of AWS R event just
heading over now to The Venue today will
be a pretty chill day yesterday we had a
lot of sessions we met a lot of people
but today I think we'll just be mainly
exploring the area um hopefully still
meeting new people but we'll see where
the day takes us so let's head over
[Music]
now
micone all right so we just got some
breakfast we're at the AWS Community Hub
and I bumped into Brian how has your re
event been so far oh it's been awesome I
mean of course the learnings and all the
feature announcements are really
exciting I think also being able to meet
people especially l i mean I followed
your YouTube channel for like how many
years now so I love the in-person
connections you just can't get that from
like the virtual or slack or LinkedIn
there's something special about bringing
a whole Global Tech Community
together so we're about running out of
time so anything
else okay so now I'm going to do an ads
quiz to test my knowledge um let's see
hopefully I don't fail too
bad
this was my previous schore but I
redeemed
myself for me was the Singapore Summit
on May the 4th where Darth Vader and I
is I know you've been to reinvent before
what's the best part OFA for sure for
first timers it's rep play but for me as
a seasoned attendee it's the user uh
collaboration works I think that's all
the most important bits let's get to the
panel so then we can go back to mix
[Music]
right oh hi rishab I didn't see you
there that was totally not planned how
are you finding reent day three so far
it's pretty good um I'm a little bit
exhausted to be honest but all the
announcement and launches has what kept
me excited okay so I've made my way to
the cloud of skos um about to meet some
new people and we're going to ask them
what their favorite AWS service is so
let's go I have a question for you what
is your favorite AWS service and why um
it's hard to pick a favorite but I'm
going to say cloud trail my favorite
service is AWS config so my favorite
service is assistance manager I love all
the AWS services but my favorite AWS
service is the AWS observability
Services okay now solve this Rubik Cube
for us all right okay no pressure no
pressure no pressure oh my God I heard
she can do it in about 20 to 50 seconds
we're going to speed up this audio a
little bit and we're going to see how
long it's going to
take already sorry that's not passing
wow good job good
[Music]
job
I met the lovely Magnolia she has given
me a pack of spicy Mexican candy to try
um so I'm going to try it out
now and
yes all right so I just had lunch and
now I'm at the observability kiosk with
Daniela Daniela so for those who are not
sure what observability is how would you
describe it yeah um so observability
with a AWS really and in the context of
um Amazon Cloud watch it gives you an
idea and understanding of how well your
systems are performing what is happening
in the systems and you do that uh by
collecting Telemetry such as metrics
logs and traces uh from multiple angles
multiple perspectives those a good
answer thank you so
[Music]
[Applause]
much
all right so it's day 4 today and uh we
had a bit of a late start we're just
going to head straight to lunch and then
go to a session after so today pretty
much counts as the last day tonight
there will be something called AWS
replay which is like a end of re event
party looking forward to it so that is
so
cool
hi Lucy oh hi
there
Lucy te with Lucy why not oh Lucy Lucy
there we go just for you thank you so
much thank
you all right so I just attended the
session what's new with AWS
observability and operations there were
quite a few interesting announcements um
and they also did a bit of a demo on
some of them one of my favorite
announcements is that Amazon cloudwatch
logs now offers automated patent
analytics and anomaly detection it
notifies users of anomalies using
Advanced ml algorithms trained using
Decades of AWS and Amazon operational
data another announcement is the launch
of my applications a new experience in
the AWS Management console for you to
manage and monitor the cost health
security posture and performance of your
applications this means users can more
easily track their applications from one
View and not to mention Amazon
cloudwatch application signals helps you
unlock the full potential of your
applications with automatic
instrumentation simplified workloads and
so on Builders can now track services
end to end from standard application
metrics to underlying Trace data okay so
this brings us to the end of all of the
AWS reinvent sessions we're now going to
head over to AWS replay which is a bu's
end of re event party so let's head over
[Applause]
now AWS reinvent 2023 was an incredible
experience with over 60,000 attendees it
was a great way to connect with fellow
Cloud Builders and learn from the
different sessions I really enjoyed
attending the three Cloud Ops sessions
as it's a great way to start learning
about managing Cloud operations for
those of you who want to take your first
step into Cloud Ops make sure you check
out the link in the description below to
watch the reent session Cloud operations
for today tomorrow and Beyond a big
thank you to AWS for sponsoring this
video and until next time happy learning
and happy
building